merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole et à monsieur georges fenech
oui monsieur le pays d'or devrait
d'abord simplement rebondir sur la
réponse de madame la ministre rossignol
istres des familles des droits de la fin
pour rappeler également la position de
notre groupe l'est républicain qui
n'agissent jamais remis en cause le
droit de la femme à l'avortement c'est
encore été rappelé ce matin publiquement
et fortement par françois fillon
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
dans le cadre d'entretiens réguliers
organisés avec le président de la
république
deux journalistes ont eu accès et ont
diffusé des documents classés secret
défense relatifs à la préparation de
frappe française en syrie et à
l'autorisation de l'élimination physique
de quatre djihadistes
ces faits qui portent incontestablement
atteinte à la sûreté de l'état et aux
intérêts supérieurs de la nation tombent
sous le coup de la violation du secret
défense
puni de 7 ans d'emprisonnement nous
avons appris hier que sur saisine de
notre collègue eric ciotti le procureur
public de paris a ordonné l'ouverture
d'une enquête préliminaire dont acte
mais monsieur le premier ministre
parallèlement à la procédure judiciaire
se pose également la question de la
responsabilité politique car on sait que
le chef de l'état bénéficiera de
l'immunité présidentielle face à la
justice ordinaire
c'est pourquoi demain le bureau notre
assemblée doit examiner la recevabilité
d'une proposition de résolution initiée
par notre collègue pierre lellouche
visant la destitution de françois
hollande sur le fondement de l'article
68 de la constitution
alors ma question est simple et
solennelle est ce que monsieur le
premier ministre votre majorité
politique acceptera d'examiner ce
manquement des devoirs du chef de l'état
manifestement incompatible avec
l'exercice de son mandat et que
justifierait selon nous une saisine de
la haute cour de justice
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
monsieur le président de l'assemblée
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député georges
fenech
vous êtes allé très clair ce que dans la
période complexe que nous traversons à
la fois internationale notamment au
levant et au sel dans la période que
vient de décrire il y un instant le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est à dire
face à une menace lourde et persistante
ma conviction profonde c'est que les
français attendent de leurs responsables
politiques une certaine hauteur de vue
et un plus grand respect des
institutions qui sont le fondement de
notre république président de la
république of le président de la
république et le chef de l'état élu par
les français par le suffrage universel
et cela que vous le vouliez ou non est
jeune elle n'est pas parce que c'est ma
conception de ce que sont les
institutions et je n'admets pas que l'on
se prête une nouvelle fois ici dans vos
rangs à la mise en cause délibérée et
systématique du chef de l'état de sa
personne et donc des attitudes
je sais bien je sais bien que vous êtes
en pleine primaire
elles ont d'ailleurs donné plutôt une
belle idée de ce qu'était la
responsabilité politique
mais ici en tout cas monsieur fenech
cela ne justifie pas tout le président
de la république a toujours pris ses
responsabilités pour combattre la menace
terroriste à travers les opérations
militaires menées par la france
que ce soit en irak et en syrie ou dans
la bande sahélo saharienne en
particulier au nord-mali les
interventions menées par le forces
armées répondent à une ligne politique à
une ligne stratégique claire qui n'a pas
varié depuis 2012
il s'agit d'éradiquer la menace
terroriste de protéger les populations
de protéger les français
ici comme à l'extérieur et de défendre
les valeurs qui sont celles de la france
alors monsieur fenech si vous voulez un
débat c'est vous que la politique
étrangère sur nos alliances sont là le
rôle et la relation par exemple avec la
russie en europe en syrie ou en irak
nous y sommes prêts mais ça c'est le
débat que demandent les français pas ce
débat qui consiste encore une fois à
remettre en cause nos institutions
et moi comme chef du gouvernement j'ai
un rôle c'est celui de défendre les
institutions et une certaine idée de la
france
merci monsieur le premier ministre